we want to do with four five floors I
want to be able to say if you can see it
you can go there right we sit on for cry
3 but we want to make sure that we give
you different locations we give you
different opportunities somebody's going
to look if you if you or I go to the
Himalayas the first thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna look up at a mountain
that has snow we're gonna go how do we
get up there
I want to give you the chance people to
go there and have a credible experience
we give you the meat that you can throw
to call the animal to be able to come in
and be able to kill somebody in the snow
we know if the wind is gonna be howling
we know that it's gonna be cold we know
that you want to be quiet we know that
everybody up there is a reason for being
there and so it's all about how you
choose to attack it with fur cry floor
we wanted to give you the feeling of
land sea and air we wanted to give you
everything so if you if you wanted to go
down into the valley and have a valley
experience and have something that was
completely different from what is up in
the freezing Death Zone on the Himalayas
you can do it and you could run
everything in between so this little
here it does begin you know you're kind
of overlooking that monastery you get to
use your wingsuit right away which is
awesome I'm very happy there's more
wingsuit on this game but then you kind
of make your way over that huge huge
chasm don't go to that little area I'm
curious like you know that that the part
where this level of said is very kind of
isolated how how segmented do the kind
of pockets of the game get its we build
a huge open world which is even bigger
than I thought it was gonna be from the
standpoint of the world is a massive
right and then what we say is okay now
we want to be able to take you to
different parts of it so there's
opportunities for you to go there and
play all these different hemispheres of
all these different biomes and all these
different animals and then somebody says
you know I want to do something a little
different I want to go and I want to
have a different not a physical
experience I want to have a mental
experience and I want to go and do
something mystical we provide you with
another world which you're gonna
discover soon within the world that is
completely mystical and then you say
well you know what I want to do I want
to go up into the top of that mountain
and I want to do something really really
quiet in the middle of a snowstorm where
I have the ability with me because I
brought meat with me and I can
effectively take the animals that are up
there and I can turn them into weapons
I was trying to piss off are those yaks
that you see at the beginning I was
trying to piss them off and as you can
yeah I noticed that they they were kind
of drawn towards the enemies eventually
I was trying to kind of like what's
there people yeah stampy them
I didn't realize ahead of me so I was
just shooting them in the butt with my
stylist assault rifle didn't work as
well do they respond well to fire if you
put a little bit of fire down and you
can get those things moving they're a
stampede right what happens when you
take all the weapons away and you say
I'm gonna play the level and I'm just
gonna use animals I'm just gonna
weaponize the animals and I'm just gonna
figure out how to bring in these animals
and basically turn them into weapons
it's nearly a diet the video games
the truth is is that we build this
living world and we build this toy box
and we're not exactly sure how people
are gonna use it so we give you the
tools and then you show us and then we
kind of sit back and watch and go I had
no idea I had no idea that was possible
and that's the best part do you find
yourself like consciously saying alright
there's a tipping point that we're
approaching we can't make it - insane -
ridiculous we have to kind of maintain a
certain level of I don't want to say
credibility but you think we try and
give you things that you or I could do
in our lives that would maybe facilitate
the dream state that you could do the
things that you could do in some of the
elements of our crime so there's always
going to be a fictional conceit that
makes it plausibly real right you could
get on an elephant and you could go when
you can do the things that you're doing
or maybe you could eat something that's
not good for you and it could put you in
a state that sent you in another way or
maybe you can get knocked unconscious
and have a weird dream
but the truth is if fun is fun and and
and if if you want to say no to fun I
don't know if that's the right spirit
for far cry